bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
il représente un français sur quatre ils
représenteront un français sur trois à
l'horizon 2050
eux ce sont les seniors engagement
associatif transmission
intergénérationnelle santé habitat
autonomie on fait le point sur nos
seniors c'est parti
[Musique]
et
t
[Musique]
je fais du sport je vais au cinéma
voilà je veux spectacle
au théâtre de saint quentin sortir tous
les jours faire les boutiques
moi je marche beaucoup à plus actifs nos
seniors le sont sans aucun doute le
territoire saint quentinois compte plus
de 35000 habitants de 60 ans et plus en
france les seniors sont pour beaucoup
dans la vitalité du secteur associatif
36 % des plus de 65 ans sont bénévole
dans une association
cet engagement se voit aussi à saint
quentin en yvelines
robert z professeur de tai-chi de sports
et loisirs seniors à maurepas enseigne
les arts martiaux depuis 52 ans
à 82 ans il partage toujours son savoir
tout comme marie-jo dans la salle d'à
côté monde de ce jour la coupe de
gymnastique douce au programme
respiration relaxation et d'étirements
[Musique]
3 2
gymnastique douce ou tonique tai chi chi
kung trois types de marche entre
promenade et randonnée tennis de table
danse folklorique
sans oublier la musculation et les
boulistes l'association offre de
multiples activités pour les seniors de
maurepas et d'elancourt à partir de 57
ans et à chacun sa préférence et la gym
le tai-chi la musculation
j'ai fait de la gym j'ai fait de chico
quelques voyages avec le thème
d'ailleurs aussi très agréable
moi je suis rentré à sports et loisirs
seniors en 2000 juste j'avais 60 ans
aujourd'hui robert vartanian est
président du club un club qui compte 750
inscrits dont plus de 60% de femmes
c'est des gens qui arrivent à la
retraite il en 60 ans ils sont très
dynamiques et ils veulent continuer à
vivre le sport le plein air le loisir le
plaisir de se rencontrer pour cela le
club organise des bals bal de printemps
val d'automne bâle de la galette
sans oublier les voyages de fin d'année
prochaine destination
la pologne de séjour de 40 personnes
prévue pour la fin août
de quoi souder les liens on est complet
complet qu'on pleure autres lieux qui
connaît un franc succès depuis 38 ans le
centre alfred de vigny à voisins le
bretonneux
mais ici ou ne pas pas de seniors c'est
un terme que l'on n'emploie pas
puisqu'on travaille avec toutes les
générations
et effectivement il ya des activités qui
sont ciblés entre 10 mai seniors mais on
cloisonne pas les choses et tous les
adhérents peuvent participer à des
activités seniors
donc on appelle ça les amis d'alfred les
amis d'alfred peuvent donc s'impliquer
dans moult activités
on va travailler sur le bien-être sur
les activités sportives de
de maintien de santé comme de la
gymnastique de la randonnée des formats
de ballades également et puis on va
travailler sur des activités manuelles
tout un tas d'activités qu'ils soient
soient techniques réfection de sièges
reliure le centre favorise également les
rencontres autour de repas partagé ou
bavardage autour d'un thé
trois mille passages sont enregistrés
chaque semaine dans les locaux d
activités permises grâce à l'implication
forte des bénévoles 110 au total parmi
lesquels daniel co fondatrice du centre
passionnée par l'art daniel s'occupe
tout spécialement de la galerie qui
permet d'exposer les oeuvres des
artistes adhérents
quand j'ai fait des études artistiques
j'ai travaillé dans la publicité nous
avons regret cette gare et d'alfred vous
voyez vous êtes entourés de tableaux de
sculptures alice ancienne enseignante
animait l'atelier mémoire
nous commençons toujours par des
exercices de moore et pour la mémoire
perturbé
quelquefois c'est lié à la galerie
d'alfred puisqu'on travaille avec daniel
sur la galerie d'alfred depuis plusieurs
années donc on fait aussi des des
exercices sur les tableaux et cognitif
effectivement c'est pour faire
travailler le cerveau dans tous les sens
et pour travailler la forme en plein air
il y aller randonner d'andré et 626
inscrit en début de saison on est assez
nombreux
on était on est monté jusqu'à 60-70 ce
même à des fois quand il ya du mauvais
temps ce quelqu'un en ce moment ça
diminue mais ce jour là ils sont 41 à
sillonner les champs et forêts près de
l'emi nul on va essentiellement dans la
vallée de chevreuse et tous les premiers
vendredis du mois ont fait debout on en
fait une première le matin et une
deuxième l'après-midi un jusqu'à 13 km
le matin 5 à 6 l'après midi
bonne ambiance assurée jusqu'au pic nic
une fois l'an les marcheurs quand une
balade au delà des yvelines destination
prévue cette année
provins au centre les bénévoles ont
trouvé une deuxième vie une idée parfois
soufflé par un proche du monde et pose
parce que quand je travaillais bon
effectivement j'étais très occupée
autrement donc je ne me préoccupe pas de
ça par contre jamais jamais beaucoup
marcher mais quand je me suis arrêté de
travailler il m'a dit il faut que tu
fasses quelque chose pour moi elle est
essentielle parce que j'aime le travail
de groupe et j'aime participer à des
activités donc pluriel on donne de son
temps mais reçoit beaucoup hostile ils
vont travailler avec des jeunes c'est
pas mal ça évitera y avait des jeunes
ses activités ses engagements permettent
de transmettre mais aussi de s'épanouir
et de rompre l'isolément la solitude
s'accroît en effet avec l'âge les liens
tissés par l'emploi n'existe plus à la
retraite et les conditions de vie
peuvent alors se dégrader habitat santé
à saint quentin en yvelines
beaucoup de projets sont à l'oeuvre pour
que les anciens conserve ce lien avec la
société la population même de notre
agglo guéi de plus en plus c'est vrai
qu'on a une grande attention vers nos
seniors dans mci galante vendu bas et
certains et sans perte d'autonomie ce ne
les empêche pas de rester chez eux et de
wacken cas à une vie tout à fait normale
quoi si bien entendu ils ont des aides à
domicile ça peut aller l'infirmière à
l'aide à domicile qui peuvent faire le
ménage
une auxiliaire de vie qui peut aider à
la toilette l'attention que l'on pense à
nos seniors commence effectivement par
l'adaptation aux loges des logements
alors qui peut prendre plusieurs formes
on sait que les bailleurs ont une
obligation maintenant dans tous les
nouveaux logements de pouvoir adapter de
proposer des logements adaptés aux
personnes à mobilité réduite et guyot
cours on a essayé de monter un de
réfléchir un projet innovant et on a un
projet en partenariat avec eiffage
france habitation et réciprocité c'est à
une résidence intergénérationnelle
dans lequel vont se côtoyer plusieurs
générations c'est-à-dire des seniors
donc avec des appartements adaptés des
familles et des jeunes
donc on espère qu'il y aura le lien
social qui va se faire offrir des
solutions intermédiaires et innovante
c'est le défi du futur programme local
de l'habitat intercommunale ceci afin de
préserver l'autonomie et favoriser le
vivre ensemble les habitats familiaux
intergénérationnelle en font partie avec
notamment des logements ergonomique des
espaces propices aux échanges et à la
solidarité entre résidents toutes
générations confondues
pour l'heure l'agglomération compte
quinze structures d'accueil résidences
services seniors et pad ou encore
résidence autonomie comme ici jean
fourcassa attrape la résidence autonomie
gens fous gaza vient de souffler ses 40
bougies en décembre dernier un lieu qui
permet d'avoir son chez soi tout en
étant accompagné 65 logements dont trois
doubles pour des couples chaque résident
possède sa propre boîte aux lettres afin
d'y recevoir son courrier en tant que
résidence autonomie nous devons des
prestations de ligue à thouars donc aux
résidents qui sont ici c'est à dire une
prestation
des dalles administratif bien sûr de
l'animation on doit aussi mettre à
disposition un accès internet avec wi fi
une lingerie de la prestation de
surveillance 24 heures sur 24 avec nos
gardiens dans chaque chambre
un bouton d'appel et un bracelet de télé
assistance en cas d'urgence les
appartements comprennent une kitchenette
afin de confectionner ses repas pour
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas profiter du
restaurant de la résidence une chambre
d'hôte est également disponible pour y
recevoir famille et amis durant quelques
jours même sillage la d'être autonome et
indépendante quelque chose qui est très
important pour votre prestation
l'animation l'animation est là pour
essayer de remplir le mans elle a essayé
de mettre un côté festif
au quotidien des résidents le soir ou
même pendant le week-end ils jouent au
baby ou biya le loto casinos les
relations intergénérationnelles avec des
petits des grands des repas festifs avec
l'association tels de trappes tous les
mois des spectacles que pour fêter les
anniversaires sortie restaurant avec un
spectale qu' il ya des visites de au
prisme à l'école de musique et de danse
le mcdo si le mcdo une fois par mois
alors au début on avait un petit rôle et
ça commence à avoir un peu plus de monde
la moitié des résidents ou entre 60 et
80 ans l'autre partie est âgé de 80 à
100 ans en france on estime le début de
la perte d'autonomie
à 83 ans en moyenne quand les habitants
quittent la résidence c'est généralement
pour aller en ehpad
une offre que souhaite enrichir
l'agglomération à montigny le bretonneux
une nouvelle maison de retraite
médicalisée vient d'ouvrir ses portes
elle accueille les personnes en perte
d'autonomie et possède deux unités
protégées destiné aux seniors atteints
de troubles cognitifs
[Musique]
autre sujet d'intérêt pour les seniors
la santé l'agglomération a été le
premier territoire francilien à mettre
en place un contrat local de santé en
bientôt une nouvelle feuille de route
sera proposé afin d'adapter l'offre de
soins le 6 juin prochain un nouveau
contrat de santé devrait voir le jour
pour cinq ans avec une attention toute
particulière envers les seniors
et tout d'abord un nouvel élan donné au
site gérontologie et handicaps dus mais
rente ai à magny les hameaux
l'agglomération a signé une convention
avec l'association pour l'insertion
l'éducation et les soins en 2017 un
soutien assorti d'une baisse des loyers
et d'une subvention de 60 mille euros
sur trois ans ceci afin de maintenir
l'offre de service deux accueils de jour
une équipe spécialisée alzheimer un
service d un service de soins infirmiers
à domicile
ainsi qu'un nouvel espace de
démonstration au dos nautique
[Musique]
ces derniers mois plusieurs maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires ont vu le jour
trappes guyancourt de nombreux médecins
généralistes et spécialistes se sont
regroupés grâce au soutien des communes
et du territoire depuis peu l'institut
de promotion de la santé a mis en place
un plan pédestre sur tra histoire de
faire de l'exercice à travers la marche
tout en découvrant la ville de lits ps à
la gare huit à dix minutes de marche de
la mairie à l'hôtel de l'agglomération
15 minutes de l'hôpital à la mairie 18
minutes
donc tout ça c'est aussi un un bien-être
de la personne si bien sûr elle est
volontaire pour sortir mais je pense que
comment dirais-je on veut en faire un
sur coignières et on va inciter les gens
se retrouver et dit robin aujourd'hui
bas on va aller du point a jusqu'au
point b ça fait 200 m mais vous aurez
fait 200 m et là aussi ça sera ouvert à
tout le monde
d'autres parcours santé découverte
devrait bientôt voir le jour dans les 12
communes de l'agglomération
depuis peu les seniors et leurs aidants
peuvent aussi s'appuyer sur le premier
guide mis en place par l'agglomération
il contient des informations pratiques
et des conseils pour faciliter la vie
des anciens au quotidien pour réadapter
leur logement à très bientôt
ciao